my talk today
is going to be about complex causality
in crises and solidarity with the
vulnerable
and i think you might be able to see
from the title of that where
some of this is going before we jump
into the talk i'd like to extend my
gratitude
towards the conference committee for
asking me to provide
this presentation and to the american
university of paris
for hosting this event and i'm very
happy to be
among a great set of other speakers i'm
looking forward to
seeing many of the other presentations
so long story short when i was asked to
give a talk for this and it's about the
psychology of global
crises it gave me the opportunity to
discuss some matters that i've been
thinking about for
quite some time but haven't completely
thought through to the degree that i'd
actually
do writing about it so what you're
getting here is a bit of raw
product you might say although it's
hopefully
had some refining done on it and
you know as we've been living through
this covid19
crisis all around the world in very
different circumstances
it really has provoked a lot of thinking
and discussions that might be helpful
and the idea of of causality which is
something that is not unique to
philosophy but i think philosophy has
some contributions
to make is is one of the things that i
want to
focus on here so the basic ideas
of this this talk are are the following
crises emerge out of highly complex
causal
interconnections and interactions and at
the same time
the human beings that are involved in
these these crises
quite often want to go to rather
simplistic views of the causality
involved
and that continues the crisis and tends
to
worsen it we don't actually have to
understand a crisis fully
in all of its causality in order to be
able to do anything useful
in the crisis but we do need to
approach things in a way that that does
some justice to the
complexity so when we understand
causal interactions and connections and
intersections
and nexuses then we we have a certain
intelligibility to what it is that we're
trying to make sense of
and this is very important from ethical
and leadership perspectives because
we you know when we approach crises like
the one that we're in with covid19
a lot of people want to get back to the
normal they want to get back to
the status quo how things were before
but one of the things that crises like
this
really bring out to us is the fact that
the status quo wasn't working for
so many people across the world and you
know the ones that we see within our own
areas communities nations so
if we shift our focus to understanding
things
in you know not not necessarily the most
complex
ways but more complex ways that will
also produce
another shift that will allow us to
focus
on something that we can call the common
good even
more importantly it allows us to shift
focus
to those who are more complexly
impacted by the crisis those who
are for a variety of reasons more
vulnerable which is where we should be
directing focus on the part of others
and
pointing our own focus as as people who
might have something to to do in this
crisis
so there are a lot of implications i
think for for ethical
decision making and evaluation and there
are also
implications for solidarity and
leadership so
that's what i'll be talking about i hope
we have a lively discussion coming out
of this
again this is sort of a work in progress
and i i won't claim to have
everything perfectly well
you know defined or worked out entirely
but i hope this can can
promote some good discussion in the
session one of the key terms in the
title
of this talk is causality and what do we
mean by causality well this is
something that we talk about quite a bit
in philosophy but it's
it's central to other discourses and
indeed we
can't get away from it in our ordinary
life
it's it's something very central to
human ways
of approaching the world and so much so
that that
emanuel kant the great you know german
philosopher
thought that causality was one of the
basic categories through which we
we understand the world david hume the
person who's rea
he's reacting to said that we can't
actually observe
cause and effect but also thought we
couldn't get away from it and there's
much more that could be said
about all the ins and outs of the
history of of this this concept
causality provides us with
answers to the question why why are
things the way they are
why did they turn out the way they did
why did this happen why didn't this
happen
why am i getting sick why did somebody
have to die
why can't we fix what's going on here
those are all things that can be
answered by thinking about causality and
as we explore the causality of things
we obtain a certain intelligibility we
another way of talking about that is we
understand things better
as we explore and investigate causal
connections and
matrices and
real things the stuff that we experience
in our our life the things that we are
going to be talking about
uh forever and acting upon are
typically complex themselves and they're
caught up within
complex causal matrices in which
there isn't a nice simple picture of
things
there are some things you know i can
turn on a light
and you know the the electricity flows
to it and
the light goes on and now i see it and
the room is illuminated
but most things don't work in quite such
a simple
way at the same time we human beings
have a tendency to want
rather simple causal explanations for
things and to prefer them and to talk
about them
quite a bit i should also point out too
that we human beings
complicate things quite a bit because
we are also causal agents
and we not only act we interpret
causality and make decisions
on what we think to be its basis and and
advise each other we engage in
deliberation so on the one hand we have
simplicity is something that we often
desire
sometimes to our detriment and the
detriment of others on the other hand we
have complexity
the contrast that i want to talk about
here
in terms of complex
and simplistic causality is not the same
thing as
simple and complex causality simple
causality would be there's some sort of
causal process and it can actually be
described in simple terms because it
actually is simple and
the vast causal networks that we're part
of are composed of
much smaller simpler parts which may in
fact
connect with each other but could be
isolated out from each other as well
if not we could never fix anything
but we also
have our explanations and our
interpretations of things
those can be simplistic
that is too simple being presented
in a way that doesn't do adequate
justice to what it is that we're trying
to
investigate so you know frequently the
things that we
are experiencing and discussing and
deliberating and choosing and acting on
they involve complex interactions and
connections so this tendency
towards over simplification is
a a problem precisely because in doing
so we are making things
too simple i'm not saying by the way
that we always need to understand
causal nexuses and connections and their
absolute fullness in order to you know
understand everything this is sort of a
relative distinction
so when we're thinking for example in
in this time of covid19 about people who
are talking about the need to reopen the
economy
why because reopening the economy will
prevent a currently existing harm which
is people being out of work and not
being able to get food and eat
that's an example of over simplistic
understandings
of causal factors and matrices
the economy by itself i mean it wasn't
actually closed if it was then then we
wouldn't have any economic activity
going on
right but the economy is an incredibly
vast thing with all of these different
things going on within it
and what we're talking about doing you
know when people
bring up this term is you know changing
this thing changing this thing changing
this thing
and notice the changes that are being
made are typically
policies or laws or injunctions
that are happening uh it's not like
we're turning on a spigot or
a light switch or anything like that but
people are are often
presenting things like that and that
causes some some issues
for us so
you know we're in a crisis we might
think of some other examples
of over simplistic ways of looking at
what's going on
some people pointing out that masks are
not 100 effective or treating
masking as if it's a panacea for
for the covid crisis or um
you know claiming that the motivations
for
having masks or uh engaging in social
distancing or
quarantines or shutdowns are these
simple things that we can identify like
people are just afraid
uh they're overreacting well that's that
you know there's a causal
explanation being provided there but
it's it's not an adequate one
others who are focused on the origins of
the virus
and spending a lot of time emphasizing
how it's the chinese virus or the wuhan
virus
you know arguably that's some over
simplistic causal thinking
as well about what's going on expecting
quick
fixes for any of this sort of stuff i
would say is over simplistic
thinking and so what's going on there
why is this a problem i mean can't we
just let people say and think whatever
they like well they will
but here's here's where the problem
arises
it's not just a failure to grasp
some of the complexity of the current
pandemic crisis
it's a failure to see interconnections
between this crisis
and other crises and problems
and along with that this insistence
on over simplistic views or schemas or
dynamics
and conflicts or narratives that
presents
the big problem now why is that the case
if we think about how causality and
crises fit together
you know we can say that a crisis occurs
because of some things that we can
identify as
a cause or causes and we might give them
sort of a capital c right
this is a crisis because of covid19
the virus and the way in which it
spreads and acts and and the
deaths and and other harms that it that
it's producing
but these sort of causes rarely
determine
matters entirely on their own there have
to be a lot of
other things going on at the same time
that are contributing playing some role
making things worse
removing obstacles that would stand in
the way of say the virus or
you know if we think about environmental
catastrophes
um some of the the things that would
prevent that from happening
and so by investigating and taking into
account and trying to grasp
more of causality we
understand things better and we also
then are able to
take into account human factors the
views the actions dynamics of other
people
and the more that we understand the more
that we
see that at least in some crises i won't
say this
necessarily for all but at least in some
before the crisis happens things are not
actually
okay although many people are telling
themselves
that things are okay there's already
going to be some
long-standing problems some people
often those who are in privileged
positions because of
power or wealth or status or
other things that place them at an
advantage
are much more insulated from what we
might call the
understructure of the crisis and so for
them it can seem like something totally
out of the blue
wow this thing happened and look how bad
things have suddenly gotten
for other people they can say no this is
a bad thing but other bad things
have been happening and now these are
actually going to intersect with each
other
so those who are worse off those who are
disadvantaged those who are
impacted by generational or community
challenges of different sorts or those
who
know interact with or support those they
tend to experience
more of the crisis sometimes they're
going to have
additional insight into what's going on
in the crisis
and they're often going to be much more
challenged by it at the same time
particularly in their ability to
communicate
with others what's happening in the
crisis and this tends to lead
to worsening
before we talk more specifically about
the covet covid19 epidemic
that we're experiencing worldwide right
now and the need for
looking at complex causality so that we
can focus on solidarity with the most
vulnerable
i'd like to look at another example that
you may be
less familiar with and that has to do
with really like over the last say
two decades what's been happening in
southern indiana
and what we can see happening there is
what we call
a not a pandemic or an epidemic but a
syndemic
syndemic means that you have several
different things coming together
at the same time that's the sin part of
it the term was coined by
the researcher meryl singer in the mid
90s and
originally was used in a a purely
medical
context and
what it what it meant was that there's a
synergistic
epidemic meaning that different factors
would would reinforce
each other it's not just the same thing
as what we call comorbidity which is
more in terms of individuals
this has to do with communities and
fairly early on they started to realize
that if we want to think in terms of
syndemics
we we also need to think about
non-biological
factors and so in southern indiana
they were having a drug addiction crisis
and they also had an aids hiv
crisis and the two of them reinforced
each other
in part because of using needles and
you know not washing them and you know
the two things kind of
went together there was also a lot of
mismanagement by the the state
uh by you know under the the governor's
uh
regime and
they realized looking at what was
happening in some of these towns where
everything sort of broke down and people
had
really bad tragic often fatal
outcomes and then looking at other towns
where this wasn't happening
that it wasn't just drug addiction and
it wasn't just
hiv and aids there were other
major factors that were playing a role
other
plagues you could say so among these
were
violence victimization and crime
policing and prisons job loss
less opportunities the jobs that were
there being more exploitative jobs more
demoralizing jobs
a lot of other other economic issues
generational
poverty uh you know foreclosures
homelessness a number of different
health issues
like diet and and you know food deserts
also diabetes and health disparities
and of course a lot of mental illness
and depression and despair you put these
things together
in a sort of again complex way and
working at one factor by itself doesn't
tend to produce
a lot of results why because the others
end up reinforcing it so it's almost
they described it as a game of
whack-a-mole you try to fix one thing
and you get some temporary fix and then
the other things rear their head
and make it uh you know people fall back
into their old
modes of behavior and so policies or
studies
that that we do often focus just on one
factor if we want to do
something about these sorts of seemingly
intractable situations
we need to approach them in messy broad
spectrum
complex ways that that do justice to the
causality
that's that's involved there so we have
to add in
other human caused disadvantages
as well we have to think about does
racism or sexism
or class or region or
other factors do those have a
bearing upon this um we we also want to
think
in in you know economic and policy terms
does having an austerity sort of mindset
that we often call
you know neoliberalism or late
capitalism
um is that impacting this this in in
even more problematic ways we might
think of people's legal status
particularly since that has become so
politicized
here in the united states and caught up
with these other complex systems
like policing we also might think about
you know bad government where corruption
turns out to to take a lot of the
resources away from
the people that they're intended to help
and direct them towards a political
class
and their preferred recipients
and another key aspect is the
lack or loss of community
the breakdown of families but also of
neighborhoods of towns and the loss of
connections
and to some degree loss of meaning
all of this happened in the crises that
were happening
in southern indiana and tended to
produce
areas not just you know single people
but
areas where crisis became
the normal state and we can see this in
in many other places as well
prime example of that is here in
milwaukee one of the
most segregated large cities in the
united states where we have incredible
disparities
in wealth education health outcomes
and things along those lines so
now when we we turn to the coved crisis
itself
we have an international virus threat
which
was not taken seriously enough by by
many
uh not at least not enough to to prevent
it from getting much worse
it's in some respects surprising that we
haven't had it even worse so far
and it's it's got a significant rate of
infection and transmission
all sorts of serious deadly effects that
you know are coming as a surprise to us
all these other things that it turns out
the virus can
do to people and at this point we have
no real effective treatment or
or vaccine so it turned into a massive
health crisis
on its own and quickly led to additional
crises so this is where we are in the
present what are these other
crises i'm just going to mention a few
and we can talk about more
in the q and a and discussion part
so one of these is economic and i i
think we could actually see this as a
number
of different crises right um there was
the need to close down
a lot of places and shift to
working at home if that's even feasible
many people have been laid off and that
introduced
all sorts of other stresses into the
systems many small businesses were
placed in
rather precarious situations restaurants
in particular which are always a
difficult
business to to keep afloat renters
were finding themselves unable to make
their rent and landlords would tell them
no i'm not going to give you any sort of
relief landlords themselves are having
problems
because they are often quite leveraged
another uh aspect of this are the the
you know what we call the essential
workers people who
are being put at risk to earn their
living some of them
being coerced into this being told that
if they
don't you know show up and
and do things in dangerous circumstances
they will not only lose their job
they'll also lose the capacity to get
unemployment
and and all sorts of other things as
well
if this isn't happening in in the part
of the world where
you're seeing the colbit crisis play out
rest assured it is happening here in
america in many places
and we have education crises we we had
to send all of these children
home so k through 12 education suddenly
had to go
online for educators who were for the
most part not prepared to
engage in online teaching colleges and
universities are in a similar
boat although they had some classes
already online
we can also talk about crises of public
spaces
and of public transportation we can talk
about crises emerging in some political
systems where
you know the the response of the
government to the
to the crisis is is you know undermining
the legitimacy of that those governments
and we have a massive problem
particularly here in america
with uh prisons where
you know these are hotbeds of infection
many people who are there in jails for
example who haven't actually been
convicted of a crime
are getting sick in cook county or
rikers or so many other places policing
courts all of those things have been
impacted as well
and the discourses that are dominating
the news
and opinion formers and social media
tend to look at things in rather
simplistic ways
this can often lead to inaction or the
wrong sorts of actions and it leads to
the perpetuation of misinformation
what we might call foolish narratives
and suggestions and mishandlings
of the crisis that we're facing
there are some additional problems here
in the united states america is
unfortunately exceptional
in these ways one thing that we can talk
about is the governmental
responses have not been particularly
good
by contrast to some of those other
countries
the trump administration congress you
know they've passed some stimulus bills
those were subject to all sorts of
political
shenanigans and wrangling and you know
we've already seen that that
some of the money was misappropriated
there hasn't been
any coordinated response in terms of
public health
important agencies once the trump
administration
took over from the obama administration
that would have helped out
were disbanded or defunded or ignored so
we're we're at a disadvantage already
but we've got some other serious
problems as well that i think
are less easily
understood by people looking at it from
the outside and one of these
is the fact that our our system if you
want to call it that
is so federal and localized states and
local municipalities
get to decide a lot of the responses to
you know public health crises and
economic crises so we're very very
dependent
on the leadership of those people in
charge
and their ethics which are oftentimes
quite
quite lacking and
things can also be sidelined by
factionalism here in my home state of
wisconsin
we've seen a stay-at-home order that the
governor
you know acting appropriately
put in in place we saw that rescinded by
the
republicans suing and going to the
wisconsin supreme court
dominated by pretty hard right
republicans who said some
astonishing things during their
decisions
and in large parts of the state we no
longer have any sort
of effective control for spreading the
the virus
because of this there another thing
that's that's often overlooked is
because of our federalism and localism
there is no system to so many important
things
there's no single education system we do
have a department of education
but they determine very little instead
we have this incredible patchwork
of school districts each of which may be
doing its own thing in states
telling everybody in the state they have
to do this thing and sometimes being
listened to
sometimes not same thing with the
colleges and universities
we here in milwaukee we have a number of
different colleges and universities
all of which are starting and ending on
different dates some of which are
planning on being
online in the fall some of whom have
already decided they're going to face to
face
there is no system again we have no
single
criminal justice or policing or prison
system instead again
a gigantic patchwork of interconnected
but often
not functionally working together
systems
so what happens in one county may be
very different from another county
we have no effective public health
system
nationwide either instead we have
you know people relying on
insurance that their jobs provide them
with or what's available on the
affordable care
act marketplaces state by state or
relying on medicaid
or medicare sometimes funded sometimes
not
many people with no insurance at all we
have a lot of people
who go into debt and bankruptcy
because of their medical costs and we
have many people who
stay away from hospitals because of that
doctors
here spend less time with their patients
than they actually do
handling paperwork um our hospitals
and insurance companies are often not
motivated particularly by public good
but by profit and we have entire
hospital groups that are owned by
venture capitalists so this is a real
problem
here in the united states the covid
epidemic
has introduced you know crises
within our framework that are in some
respect more problematic
because the causality is more complex
than
in other places where there's a better
coordinated response
so what are the results of this
well when it comes to vulnerable
communities and
populations this sort of crisis
and the fact that there's a complex
causality to it
makes them even more vulnerable
in many respects and in complex ways
that because they're complex we would
have to engage in some discussion some
investigation
some examination in order to make sense
out of it
at the very same time privileged groups
and populations often are engaging in
denying some really basic facts
engaging in calls to reopen a rather
mythical
notion of the economy saying that that's
where the real crisis lies
we have others who are stressing their
own personal rights and freedoms
engaging in protests
um you know refusing to wear masks
calling that
tyranny some of them coming in armed a
lot of non-compliance as well i
you know when i take walks around here
i'm sometimes the only person wearing a
mask in
downtown milwaukee and so you know
what's going on
the dangers the harms the risks
they exist and the privilege might be
affected by it so you know every once in
a while we see something that looks like
a bit of poetic justice
where somebody who is denying that there
was a crisis and saying that they would
keep their business open
and they'd never wear a mask and they
protest they get sick
that does happen to quite a few people
but
for the more vulnerable people the risks
the dangers the harms
are greatly compounded and
you know we can we can talk about this
in in demographic
forms uh i mentioned that here in
milwaukee we're one of the most
segregated cities in the united states
here in the city of milwaukee the bulk
of the kovid 19 cases and deaths were in
the african-american
community that's changing now as
as the disease you know is reaching a
broader
spectrum of people i think that
one of the things that we we need to
stress when it comes to those who are
vulnerable is that while many people
think that we just need to return to
normalcy
in reality things were not okay before
the crisis
and things are not going to be okay
after the crisis
unless some significant changes are made
so those who want to return to an okay
status quo treating things in a very
simplistic way
really what they want to do is to keep
their positions
some are trying to you know make even
more money or exploit the crisis
and this this comes if we want to think
about this in an ethical perspective
by being interested in themself or
others like themselves
and not being interested in the others
the vast ver
you know uh majority of people who are
going to be negatively impacted by it
and these typically go along with rather
simplistic views on causality about what
the crisis is and how to fix it
how things aren't connected to each
other that actually are connected
who is impacted and how they're impacted
there's a tendency to write off
people who are impacted and also a
tendency
to say well you know they they knew what
they were getting themselves into or
they're getting paid for that or
things along those lines it was the
opposite of solidarity
now i'm not suggesting that we need to
have some sort of
radical or revolutionary measures
at this point in time things are already
bad enough and we probably don't have
the consensus to do much of that at
least here in the united states
but what i am suggesting in terms of
ethics and in terms of leadership
is that we really ought to be directing
the focus to
two main concerns one would be for
some sort of genuine common good or
common goods
the other would be to the people who are
most vulnerable or even just more
vulnerable
and that means thinking about the why
why are these people more at risk than
others why
do they die at a higher rate why
do they have a harder time getting
access to medical care
why are other things impinging on them
why for example
are people who are being honored as
heroes also being shot by police
officers
we could go into many of these sorts of
things
so i think that here's my basic point
solidarity with the vulnerable is going
to require
that we take non-simplistic approaches
and views
and we also keep common goods in view
it's not enough
just to say well we need to look to the
common good
we also need to investigate and think
about
and advocate for and make actions and
and you know engage in public
deliberation about
how these people and these people and
these people are impacted often
in different ways but in ways
that place them at greater risk and
cause
greater harm for them crises possess
ethical implications and dimensions and
those run
throughout the entirety of those
i'm not going to try to provide you here
with some sort of overarching theory of
ethics and crises or you know
go into moral theory in any great depth
i'm just going to say a few things and
we can talk about this
more in the discussion so
two things right off the bat i i've
mentioned so far that we need to be
attentive to the common good
and we need to be in solidarity with
those who are
vulnerable and i'm not going to talk
much more about the common good in the
ethics
portion of this in part because i want
to keep things short but also because i
think we can talk about that more
in our discussion suffice it to say that
the common good and attentiveness and
solidarity
with the vulnerable are not going to be
at odds with each other in any
well understood way of articulating
these
and when it comes to moral theories
whether it's virtue ethics ethics of
care deontological ethics
various uh you know properly understood
religious ethics even utilitarianism
if they're actually well understood and
applied in the right way we are going to
see all of these
stressing the need to take care
of those who are most vulnerable
the only exception to that would be
ethics that are
you know primarily self-centered whether
they be straight out egoism
or the kind of you know libertarianism
that places an exclusive stress
on my rights as opposed to everybody
else's rights
but other moral theories are again
rightly understood
going to focus on those who
are vulnerable so what does solidarity
mean i think that without again getting
into great detail about this
we can say that there are a number of
different aspects
each of which is a set of obligations
to be concerned and care and act
and so action is one of the primary
things that we can talk about we have a
duty to act
in such a way as to try to
help those who are and
we might say to to um
shield or protect those who are most
vulnerable and we can talk about this in
positive ways
and in in negative ways the negative
ways being trying to ward
off evils that are going to happen to
them but we can also talk about helping
people out
and doing positive actions
which might sometimes just be you know
transferring
some some money but oftentimes may
include all sorts of other things as
well
so we want to be prudent in in how we're
you know acting and we want to do so in
such ways
that will help out those who are under
the greatest stress those who are
risking harm not just from kovid 19 but
from perhaps losing their place of
residence or
in trouble for for other things you know
so
that's one key aspect another i would
say
is a duty to advocate for
very often those who are most vulnerable
are also the least listened to so
without trying to you know make
ourselves
the the objects of attention we can use
the fact that we
often do have more privileged positions
that we're listened to more often to
speak
for others to try to advocate for them
as as best as we can
and i think we also if we want to talk
about
complex causality we really do have an
obligation to
try as best we can to understand the
conditions of
others and why
some people are at much greater risk and
disadvantage
than others and why simple solutions
are often going to negatively impact
them because of
things that people didn't think about or
leave them behind
we also i would say have an obligation
going along with that
to call out and criticize those who
are mistreating the vulnerable those who
are exploiting them
those who are doing things that
actually accentuate or perpetuate
the harms against them and all of this
can be done
in many different ways and we have many
different opportunities
for engaging in this i'm not going to
get more specific
than this at this point in time but what
i will
highlight is that if we if we do
understand these crises
in complex ways that do justice at least
to some degree with the
many different ways in which causality
is taking place
we see those people caught up within
those frameworks and we can see that
that
that's where the priority really ought
to be
to bring this to a close the last thing
that i wanted to mention
is leadership and i would say that
in this crisis what we've seen is
quite a few people who are leaders in
name are not
genuine leaders because they're lacking
in some of the key dimensions of
leadership and just let me
i'll lay them out for you very quickly
here so
crises do in fact require leadership for
coordination
for having some sort of you know
response that can can
ward off harms and and help produce
better outcomes
so one key aspect of leadership is
actual decision making and many of the
decisions that genuine leaders have to
make
are quite difficult decisions they have
to weigh
a number of different bad outcomes
against each other
and choose between them and they have to
take responsibility for it full
responsibility
they can't push it off on to others they
have to be willing to
to accept that another key thing that
leaders have to be able to do is to
communicate effectively
to the public to those who they are
making decisions
who you know decisions that are going to
affect
all of these people the the community at
large and they also have to be able to
try to communicate even with
people who are opposed to them to try to
get them on the same page they may not
be totally successful with that
there's two other dimensions of
leadership and this goes to you know the
the
title of this paper that i think are
absolutely essential here as well
one of them this is where many people
are failing in leadership right now
is that there's a duty to be informed to
actually
know what they're talking about to seek
out information
to seek out experts to seek out those
who have
experiential expertise and understand
how things are happening
on the ground without this there's no
real leadership
it's it's just flailing around in a
blind way or following ideology
or you know providing rational
rationalizations rather than you know
practical reasoning for what one wants
to do
the other thing is leadership must be
ethical or it's not
genuine leadership i've mentioned
already that the common good is
something that leaders need to start
paying more attention to and some
leaders have
but i think that this this aspect of the
focusing on the most vulnerable and
solidarity with them is really quite key
and i'll
use the example of essential workers we
do have many people
who are essential workers they don't
have to be called heroes
they don't actually need people clapping
for them they certainly don't need
airplanes flying over it to honor them
what they need is
more ppe and you know better conditions
and making sure that when they're coming
home
from you know putting themselves at risk
that they're not at risk
because of other things like policing or
bankruptcy or all sorts of
you know other complex causal factors so
a
genuine leader in this situation
would be somebody who would look at this
crisis
in a way that sees the complexity of the
causality
and that would lead them to seeing
the need for solidarity for
with the most vulnerable
all right thank you dr sadler for this
uh great keynote speech
um i want to encourage participants
who are joining us here um to use the q
a function
so if you have any questions please post
them on the
under q a and then um make sure to
upload also your favorite questions and
we'll try to get to them and if there
are any questions we don't
um answer now we can actually go to
slack and dr
sadler can engage with them there uh so
i want to start with the question i
really like the question
or the um the idea of complex causality
as someone
that is trained in psychology human
science and teaches research
because of course uh in the mainstream
scientific tradition
causality is seen it's related to other
concepts linearity
tends to be kind of unidirectional a
causes b
right you want to really isolate
variables and factors to really
determine for sure
uh the cause and if you can't do that
then it's not experimental it's not
scientific
it's something that's less it's not
theory it's not fact you can say it's a
correlation
uh you can say it's a hypothesis but you
can determine that it's a theory or a
fact
uh the other notion i think that's
related to it as well is uh
temporality right time is a big part of
it and i think when i was listening to
your talk i was
uh aristotle's notion of final causality
came to mind as a kind of more
interesting
approach to causation um yeah
and so if you can if you can speak to
that a little bit um the scientific
approach
and the experimental approach
specifically of trying to isolate
variables
to to produce a theory or a fact and
what you're talking about
yeah and so i'll also say that
we can bring in sort of uh you know the
way the philosophy tends to treat
causality and the way that policy makers
tend to
treat it and i would say that there's a
tendency towards
abstraction and oversimplification in in
all of this right
policymakers like there to be things
that they can not necessarily say
are scientific in the social science way
but at least can sell to a public and
say oh this this is
causing this so for example the virus
has caused
the economy to to close down and that
that is causing people to be
out of work which is putting them at
risk and so we have to reopen this this
vast thing called the economy which is
really an abstraction
and yeah in the social sciences i
understand why
why there's this impulse to to try to be
able to
to to say um we have a very rigorous
approach
to these sorts of things but but reality
is is complex
and um when we're dealing with with
crises which this conference is about
i think we have to be aware that that
there is a
vast complex causal nexus behind a lot
of these these things and crises
don't just get caused by some you know
independent variable that wasn't
sufficiently attended to it's usually
caused by a whole host of things that
that often uh uh interact with each
other
in complicated ways but it often reveals
as we're seeing in this covid crisis
particularly here in america that there
are
many other crises that get sort of
absorbed into it and
can that be handled effectively in
in the ways that um would satisfy the
the the desires of social scientists
perhaps not
um or it can be done in a very piecemeal
way
i think that approach that's been taken
in terms of looking at things as
syndemics is quite useful and that does
come out of social science as well as
medicine
um i think i lost the train of
the second part of what you're asking
follow-up would be uh
another word that came to mind as you
were talking is reasoning
because reasoning and causality like
causality for me has this very specific
connotation that has to do with
yeah like a causes b whereas reasoning i
think
an an interesting alternative yeah and
i'll introduce a couple other
terms too deliberation is also important
there
and then reflexivity human beings and
this
you know um this is not something new
that i'm saying this has been said by
people like aleister mcintyre and
other people who've looked very closely
at the social sciences
you know one of the issues with with the
one of the difficulties with the social
sciences
is that we're we're dealing with with
subjects that are reflexive as soon as
they start realizing that you're
studying them
they resist that or subvert it in
different ways and
and they can also like use the
information that's coming to them and
and then reassess things and
deliberation is something that we do as
individuals like should i go and buy
more toilet paper or not you know
seems like we're running out or we can
do it in more public
ways and deliberation involves uh
reasoning
not always necessarily good reasoning or
well-founded reasoning
but reasoning nonetheless we we are if
we think about this
in philosophical anthropology ways we
are the
the rational animal the logical zohan as
aristotle said
and so we do reason these things out
with all of this input coming in from
other things including the emotions
and uh the other side of that is that we
are the communicative animal so when i
see you reasoning about something i can
pick up that line of reasoning and say
this is pretty good
or i can respond to it and say well that
guy's terrible i need to you know
flame him in some way and call out his
his horrible reasoning
or anything in between so yeah
maybe those are better ways to talk
about it than causality but but i wanted
to use this term causality because there
is indeed
a a you know vast causal set of nexuses
that are that are connected together and
and
in philosophy when we talk about
causality and i think you can say a
similar thing in the social
sciences we are as we're investigating
it we are
wrapping our heads around things complex
phenomena that we want to be able to
react to make decisions in terms of
and so there's a kind of intelligibility
as we penetrate further into
the causality and resist the temptation
to oversimplify
thank you for that and um did you ever
like
think about aristotle's notion of final
causality because
i think it's interesting to think of how
he's not thinking a before b
that's the cause but that the cause
could be future oriented that's
something that's kind of pulling as
opposed to
pushing right so that's interesting to
think about too
and i'll say that that that works in
ways that can be very useful for us and
it also works in ways that are
causing problems so one way of
of oversimplifying uh causality in this
crisis
is to attribute motives to other people
which which we have to do
because otherwise human actions are um
unintelligible but the people who are
saying for example well
you know this is really a vast
government conspiracy to get us to wear
masks and social distance and have power
over us
they're attributing a kind of kind of
causality to things right the the crisis
which you know uh
has been going on for a while is really
being pulled in this this
future plan direction which you know i
mean
is it possible that that that actually
could have
been the case that there's a vast
conspiracy sure
is it is it probable in any way i think
not you know
but we can also talk about um other
things that fit in more with what i was
discussing before so if you think about
if we switch back to the indiana
example where they started talking in
terms of syndemics
you know when you have a drug abuse
epidemic and you're trying to
produce programs and legislation and
policies that are going to
fix things you're you're looking towards
the future there's there's a
purpose an end to telos that's that's in
mind
and it becomes this unfortunately in
cases like this a game of whack-a-mole
when you're dealing with the most
vulnerable
because as it turns out there's all
sorts of other things that are impinging
on them
dealing with trauma and violence mental
illness
generational poverty you know lack of
of job opportunities and those you know
also affect the person so if we can
think about
how we don't have to think in a utopian
way of like oh we're going to solve all
of you know humankind's problems at once
but we think about okay we've got a
problem with this and we've got a
problem with this and we've got a
problem with this and we need to plan
out teleologically how we're going to
deal with those
sorts of things so we're actually
addressing the problems across
a broad spectrum in ways by the way that
are going to be messy and not not
satisfy
a lot of policy makers and social
scientists
then i think we could actually start to
do things for those who are more
vulnerable
okay here's a question from one of the
participants how can we call for
solidarity in global when the
communities are most affected by crises
for example in a past tense the hiv
crisis are insufficiently solid
for lack of better words in and of
themselves and if such
solidarity can be acquired or developed
how do we maintain that condition
well i don't think solidarity is
etymologically
connected with solid um so
that i don't think that that that's
something that we have to
take as a a real objection
um but one of the challenges
in um exhibiting solidarity which is a
relative term it's not something like an
on off switch
it's going to be we can have more or
less of it
there would have to be a lot of uh for
for many people sort of like
reaching out and figuring out what's
going on in particular communities
and happening to uh particular people
and we often do this
in terms of looking at representative
cases you know so for example
on twitter and unfortunately i don't
know the woman's name because there's so
many cases like this popping up but
there was a recent thing about
uh an african-american nurse who was
shot in a
botched police raid and
you know she's been one of the people on
the front line in the covit epidemic
and then you see that that the crisis
that we're having in policing
impinges upon her because she's
unfortunately in one of the
uh you know when it comes to policing
one of the most vulnerable
populations or groups right how can we
have solidarity i mean
we can have solidarity in part by saying
something needs to change here
we can have solidarity by going out as
best as we can
into communities by advocating you know
i don't think that we
we have to um try to change everything
as
and as a matter of fact you know it's
interesting robert you mentioned the
factor of time
none
corrective about who we're going to try
to engage in or exhibit solidarity with
and will inevitably leave out far more
people than we than we will
manage to help that does not mean that
we're not doing something
that's that's good or fulfills a moral
obligation on our part
because the the real good that you
manage to do
is actual it's real and it won't solve
everything but at least it's
it's something
thank you here's another question from
uh participant what tools
or strategies do you suggest to promote
complex thinking
on these issues for example in a
classroom
oh in the classroom that's an
interesting twist on it
um i mean we do case studies in in
ethics classes
and i think in you know it's kind of a
common model for like business
classes and also for for uh medical
things
and good case studies are usually going
to be messy and murky and you have the
students
do a first pass at them and some of them
come up with with very
quick answers and then you you start
digging into it to figure out why those
answers are only partly right
um that's and that's just one of many
different things you can do i'm not
saying that's the one
one approach that you would have um i
think that you know teaching
something about the informal fallacies
can actually be quite helpful
or as they get called in other places
cognitive biases right
these these ways in which reasoning
particularly practical reasoning about
what we ought to do or what not to do
can go astray many of them when we
diagram them out turn
to be turn out to be based on
oversimplifications and not attending
sufficiently to things
so i mean those are just a few
suggestions
i think i don't know that we could
actually work out an entire curriculum
that would be applied across the board
for this but
it's kind of an interesting prospect to
think about
i feel also like tapping into the
collective
mind of the students and you know
logically that's part of
uh you know uh tapping into that
complexity as well
yeah getting students to learn from each
other through through engaging each
other right
yeah yes and here's another question uh
how do we
go about encouraging people to take
serious such a duty
uh to be informed which seems to be
essential to community life
oh that's that is a really good question
some people do take that seriously
already
and so we i think we don't have to worry
about them except for the ones who
are very selectively informed right the
ones who say
well you have to do your own research
but it turns out the reason is only
looking at this very narrow spectrum and
maybe we want to get them to
look at at more things that would um
expand their their horizons that way
that is a tough one um i i think this is
one of those cases
where the old expression um
you know consistent pressure
relentlessly applied
play plays in we we don't have one
single
set of things or approaches that we take
we just keep saying
here's some more information this is
important and it is tough because we are
within an attention economy
which tends to favor the either the
trivial
or the easily schematized
over the more complex stuff so
we're i don't want to say we're always
going to be fighting a losing battle but
we're always going to be certainly
coming from behind when it comes to that
here's another question from the
community how do you think the treatment
of u.s
prison inmates during our covet crisis
reflects
on the ethics of the government do you
think the treatment of inmates versus
treatment of the non-prison constituency
have taken parallels
yeah this is this is a a very
big problem and and i do want to say
something that i i mentioned
within the um presentation
we have no prison system here in the
united states instead we have a federal
prison system
which does not house most of our inmates
then we have
you know 50 different state departments
of corrections each of which is its own
animal some of which are particularly
horrific and then we have all of these
county jail systems
as well cook county jail system is
larger than some state docs
and what you can say is that there
at least in my experience i've never
seen a particularly well-managed prison
system uh it's just you know how poorly
managed they are and how many problems
there are
you're also dealing with infrastructure
that often tends to be quite old and not
well maintained like when i was teaching
at indiana state prison
you could smell mold everywhere it's one
of the oldest prisons
in indiana and i thought man if i had a
mold allergy i would be
in hell living here and so we've got all
that sort of stuff in the background
now we're also we also have a legal
system that
that unfortunately um
is a system but it it tends to really
disfavor
treating prisoners the way that that we
ought to
um in part because we put people into
jails
uh awaiting trial which can go on for a
very long time because prosecutors can
can use it as leverage
uh with people you know we're gonna
we're just gonna leave you here for a
couple months
get you to plead to a lower offense and
then
when people are when people ought to be
released from prisons
um very often the state
it's usually the local prosecutors will
try to resist that as much as possible
in order to
appear tough on on crime so
right now we have some not only do we
have the the usual
inequities and poor management that
we've had already
but we literally have people who are
being given the potentiality of a death
sentence
even though they haven't been convicted
because they're stuck in rikers island
or in cook county jail or
even in our jails here in in wisconsin
about which is very difficult to get any
information about covet by the way in
the wisconsin doc
and and jail systems so you know
this this is a major problem um does it
parallel what's going on on the outside
i would say it's much worse
in many respects but the prison system
is part of the criminal justice
system which also fits into this this
entire discussion of
vulnerabilities and which which people
are more disadvantaged
um here in milwaukee one of the
most segregated large cities in the
united states we can say that the brunt
of policing
falls on minorities and
you know the criminal justice system and
therefore the the prison system and the
spread of kovid within the prison system
is going to impact
the african-american community and on
the south side the hispanic community
much
more heavily than than the the larger
community
so it's a little bit of a long-winded
answer i think but
there's a lot more to be said about the
prison issue i think
i do have a question about uh complexity
because i
i personally love complexity and this is
kind of a more
general question you are in the minority
then right
right uh and uh you talked about
leadership in the end and
yeah i'm thinking i always think about
human organization
uh particularly because when you look at
the environment that we're situated in
and when you look at the universe as a
whole it's this big
context the cosmos it's complex right
and we are complex and yet human beings
create these uh hierarchical simplistic
structures that are very rigid and not
complex
right and complexity we know when when
you study complex systems they're
actually
much more flexible they adapt better and
they're much more sustainable so they
last longer
when you create a hierarchical rigid
system
let's say uh where the power is just
concentrated like
a pyramid all the way to the top that
kind of system
sure it gives you a high on power but it
doesn't last long it's not sustainable
and it's not efficient so this this this
kind of
um i think about a lot about this and i
want your thought on this why
human beings do not just align
themselves with how the universe is
organized and create
uh complex systems that actually would
last better would be more efficient more
democratic
all of that that's that's a big question
um so i would say that
for one thing the sort of rigid higher
hierarchies systems
are also drawing upon all sorts of
complex systems to
to support them um and the question is
whether whether there's any
attentiveness to that
so you know a great example of this is
is the discourse right now about
reopening the economy when people when
people say that
i i often kind of tune them out at this
point because i'm like the economy never
closed
um you know you just can't go to the
barber like you'd like to or you know
shop in the the
you know costco in in the way that you'd
prefer to without a mask and
you know lingering over items and
touching everything and
that sort of thing um because there you
know
there are vast sectors of the economy
that are that are going like gangbusters
construction is a prime example
we live right here downtown in milwaukee
and the one thing that hasn't stopped
and has actually
increased is is construction in part
because
it's a great way for the city and the
county to keep spending money
and put it into the hands of people who
are going to spend the money and keep
the economy
going so you know there there's there's
the
reality the complex reality of all these
interlocking systems and then there's
the sort of ideological representation
which tends to be over simplistic and
you know i was joking that you know
you're in the minority and preferring
complexity but that's quite true
most most people do like for things to
be nice and simple because it's
manageable it reduces anxiety
and the feeling that we don't really
know what the hell's going on
i mean that's the thing too with complex
systems we only know
like bits of what's happening over here
and we have to make sort of educated
guesses which
could be wrong which is less attractive
than
you know coming down from on high and
having the great leader who's going to
to tell us exactly how things are are
going to work whether it be
um you know uh and i don't want to get
too much into politics here but
you know sort of a leader who kind of
makes it up as he goes along or a
technocrat like obama was or
um somebody who's much more of a
you know allowing the cabinet to do the
job like george bush was or
things things along those lines um
the you know to to exercise leadership
in in today's situation i think would
require
being very attentive to these
complexities and like i said
there has to be a not not a sort of like
bill clinton ask oh i feel your pain
or you know and i think it's quite
difficult for people who have leadership
positions to
to genuinely identify and and exhibit
solidarity towards those who are most
vulnerable because they are taken out of
those
those situations by having been going up
that hierarchy
in leadership even if they came from
humble beginnings
but i think that is an ethical
imperative that they they ought to be
if they're not themselves looking at
things in in
a way that at least goes to the tip of
the iceberg of the complexity at least
they're
the people surrounding them who they
take advice from
ought to be doing so and so we're in a
particularly bad situation here
in the states i think um
and and we're in a bad situation here in
the states too because of our
our particular you know emphasis on
federalism and local control because
you know some of our governors are doing
a great job others are doing terrible
jobs
um some of our mayors you know
exhibiting leadership
are are doing a good job as can be done
in this situation and others are
going for easy solutions that that are
not going to be helpful for
not just for for us as a whole
but particularly for those who are are
already
disadvantaged i also like that you use
the word leader because
i the leader for me is someone that
leads by example
so i literally think of a leader that's
an on the front line
uh that you know exposing themselves to
danger
to kind of not just someone that's
sitting comfortably and telling people
what to do
which is the boss model right so i think
that the word leader is a really
important
one because you're literally at the
forefront right you're the vanguard
and so i think that's a that's a an
important
uh thing to emphasize i think that's
right and
and i think that that's very well put i
don't i don't have anything to add to
that one
all right so uh we're almost close to uh
the end do you have any final thoughts
or
any questions from the participants
um well i mean i want to thank all of
you for for inviting me to this this is
really a
a great thing to put on and i think it's
very helpful that it's recorded because
we can use this now
in um in our classes
and and spread it much more widely these
these sets of discussions and
interdisciplinary conferences like this
are particularly helpful i think
well thank you very much uh we really
appreciated your keynote and
the q a so hopefully you'll engage with
the participants on uh
slack yeah i'll see if i can
if i can get to it i may be a little bit
slow because i'm still in
in the middle of grading which is one of
the worst things about being an
instructor but but it's very important
right giving feedback
to the students i don't know anybody who
likes grading
except for people who like to give bad
grades but
we've all had professors like that right
all right but it is it is
and actually that's kind of a good thing
to go out on so
you know i've talked a lot about the
nature of crises and complexity and
causality and then you know these sort
of
ethical and leadership dimensions but
communicative dimensions are really
important
um being able to uh you know give each
other feedback i think you've got this
wrong i think you left this
out um and then being able to take that
and and
bring that in that's sort of like what
you're talking about a leadership
might be you know framed in more
democratic terms
thank you very much
you